Now--what happened is--we set our form action to be google.com/search--
we can see here in our URL--and the form added the value
that we typed in on our form to the q parameter.
Remember--q came from our HTML.
It's the name of the input element--it's the name of that text field.
And that's why we keep seeing it in the URL.
Let's go back to our form.
Okay--I'd like you to type something else in the form,
and you're going to tell me what happens.
This time we're going to type in better flight search--and click submit.
Okay--so--what I'd like you to do is go to your form,
type the phrase "better flight search" into the form, and click submit.
What I'd like you to tell me is what is the value of the q parameter in the final URL?